[Music]
good morning my name is Bob Schieffer
and on behalf of MIT the lab for
computer science the MIT X consortium
project Athena and other sundry people I
welcome you to the Bahamas registered
attendance for this conference was up in
excess of a thousand so a few people
have probably are frozen
somewhere between wherever they are and
here we have a lot to get through so I'm
not really going to say much more I'm
gonna ask that the speakers introduce
themselves as they come up so that I
don't have to keep popping up and down
due to technical difficulties we're
gonna have a slight rearrangement of the
morning agenda so without further ado
we'll go into our first talk
sure
okay just a second here
hi I'm Joe Bowyer from Apollo computer
okay when you start at most window
system so they take over the whole
screen the X sample server takes over
the whole screen at Apollo we're
interested in integrating the X server
so that it shares the screen with other
Windows systems if x y and z our window
systems we like XY and z to coexist on
the same screen we'd like the user to be
able to access XY and z windows on the
same screen
let's see first slide one back please
yeah I have the master control here
anything okay
okay there you see an example of the
Apollo Windows system when we shipped
our first note in 1981 it came with a
Windows system on it I was shipped to
Harvard University I was still schooled
in school at the time and so our
customers have had seven years to
develop code which uses and requires the
Apollo Window System so the first reason
we want to try to have X share the
screen with other Windows systems is so
that we can give our customers X Windows
without taking away their old Windows
system the second reason is
functionality in this example you see a
3d graphics and a window on the left and
interleaf text publishing system on the
right eye you can use dinner leaf as you
can tell to do the slides and 3d
graphics it's an example of something
which is available in the Apollo Window
System which won't be available in X for
a while
interleaf is an example of a complex
application which may take some time to
port to X in general Windows systems
have their advantages we want to try to
offer all the advantages at the same
time
another reason is extensibility by
integrating the windows systems together
we have a platform to which new windows
systems can be added in the future this
is a an ex-green it's rather sparsely
windowed because i'm leading up to
something you've got X clock in the
corner and X term down the bottom
just a minute here I'll switch there you
go now the question is what do you get
when you but when it's just two window
systems together here's one idea if you
integrate them at the video level it's
sort of X plus y over 2 I don't think
special glasses will help with this one
either
here's an example you can I meant to
unobscured one of the X windows they're
both obscure on obscure sorry I meant to
obscure one of the X windows they're
both unobscured and that's how you can
tell this is a real sliding out of fake
one of it slide fake that I would have
unobscured I would have a scared one of
the windows let's see there's that
did you see that you know it's just a
that's what you get okay this is one of
those three-part talks I'm going to talk
about the strategy for doing this and
then a little bit about the
implementation and then I'll conclude
okay first of all how are we going to
integrate these windows systems or how
did we integrate the windows systems you
can consider three options one is if
they were all server based windows
systems you could merge them at the
protocol level just merge the protocols
together and make one big super server
that that does both of the things
unfortunately Windows systems are not
all server based there there are
procedure based Windows systems the
Apollo Window System is an example of
this where the window and graphics
routines are in a library and the
applications call directly into the
library so that we go on to number two
you can layer one Window System on the
other in this case you would layer the
procedure based system on the server
based system the problem here is one
you're going to degrade performance in
the procedure based system because
you've introduced this additional layer
to you you're probably gonna have
compatibility problems since you've
reimplemented most of your procedure
based system three there's there's also
a problem with direct memory access to
the screen at procedure based systems
often let the applications directly
manipulate the bits on the screen and
that's something that server based
systems can't do without some fulling so
we we get to number three which is to
build a shared Window System nucleus
build a Window System nucleus that all
the windows systems use
before I get on to the implementation
let me talk a little bit more about what
this means to have shared window systems
by one at one point is by sharing the
Window System nucleus all the windows
systems can access all the windows on
the screen even the ones they didn't
create in this example you see the X
Window is the root there's a Y window
one of the children is you window one of
the children and if you run an X window
manager for example you'll be able to
move and resize the X window and the Y
window one of the tasks and integrating
and Window System is that you need to
fix it so it doesn't lose its mind if it
sees windows that it didn't create the
other point about this is that if you
say use the X window manager to change
the size of window of the y window then
the Y window system because it's sharing
the nucleus will find out about those
changes and another thing you have to do
when you integrate window systems is to
fix it so it doesn't lose its mind if
someone else changes one of his windows
we give the the window system that
created the window squatter's rights on
the window that that the that is the the
window system that created the the root
being the X Window System gets to
control the background pattern in the
cursor shape and the border width you
can run two window managers at once but
we don't think that's particularly
useful so we aren't trying to bend over
backwards to to make that work we only
support one window manager at a time you
might also note that if the integration
is done correctly then you could run to
X servers on the same screen if anyone
knows why you would want to do that I'd
like to know
now in order to build a the shear
nucleus need to find out what things
have to be shared and here's a list of
the things we have thought of you need
to share the window database so that the
window when every windows system can
access all the windows and find out
about changes to the windows they care
about you need to share the input you
need to share screen resources the
gravities controllers the screen memory
the color look-up tables the screen
saver the mechanism that turns off your
video if you haven't talked to the
screen for a while that all needs to be
shared
also selections for example we'd want to
be able to cut and paste between windows
of different windows systems I'll talk
more about the window database and input
in a minute the as far as screen
resources the gravis controllers and
screen memory just need a some sort of
fair dispatch mechanism that'll that'll
give every window system a chance the
color lookup table we're implementing a
superset of the X color model and having
excuse that okay here's what we need to
share in the window database the
position size of the windows the so that
when Window System can change the
position size of another window and and
the that'll all work the window clip
region the next window can obscure a Y
window and that needs to be handled at
the clip region stage parents siblings
and children you can have an X window as
a parent of a Y window and vice versa
the class input output or input only
this determines how the clip region is
computed and status information such as
these flags such as exposed obscured
mapped also an indication of whether the
window has been changed recently for
example a flag that tells you whether
the position has changed note that
there's no border within the window
database that's every window system
needs to augment the shared database
with its own special needs and
the border with is something that X
would handle by itself we also need to
share properties we define a superset of
the X properties and the other windows
systems every Windows system implements
its properties using that superset so
that for example the when a client of
one Windows System can't communicate
with the window manager of another
Windows system via the shared properties
we also need a global ID and that's the
handle by which window is passed from
one window system to another we intend
to have supply Apollo extensions which
where you can pass in a global ID and
get the X Window ID back and pass in an
X window ID and get the global ID back
also a few special features of the
database the Windows systems can use the
status information to find out about
changes to the windows they care about
and for example they will notify
interested clients about the changes
clean up their own act and that sort of
thing the this this kind of
notifications after the fact we have a
couple of features that that give us
warning as the action is happening or
before the policy groups a a window can
be associated with any number of policy
groups and when the windows being
operated on the policy group gets a
chance to modify the operation that's
that's used to implement redirection in
X the substructure redirect gets one
group and resize redirection gets
another group we also have a window
system can select advanced damage
warning on a window and then when the
window is before the window is damaged
the just before then the window system
is called back and given a chance to
save the bits that's needed for backing
store in X
here's our model for input for the
shared input event center from the
devices that are serialized and an
assigned timestamps and then they may be
translated discarded turn into different
events or more complex things might
happen then there are demultiplexer
routed to the interested clients each
each window system would have a queue
that it would route its events to the
routing is done with focus trees this
isn't nearly complete but it's still too
complicated and what was I trying to
show we we have a slightly more general
model of input then then X the focus
treats and the windows are not
one-to-one necessarily this has two x
windows and one y window and there's a
separate focus tree
these are windows here
these are windows here and these are
Sagan sorry okay these are these are
focused streets here we have a separate
focus tree for the pointer and for the
keyboard so that the so that they can
have separate focuses in this example I
think I'm showing that the pointer is in
window x2 so you activate the focal path
associated with that that would be the
kind of routing where the window that
contains the pointer is the window that
gets the then and
we have a bindings or this sort of
generalized translation thing that we
have which can be just do simple
translation such as mapping and X and
they can also do something more
complicated
for example the passive grab you can
implement a binding which when it sees a
certain button and modifier combination
will activate the grab okay how much of
this is real how much is imaginary as
you saw from the as you saw from the
slide there's a lot of it's real we've
implemented the core of the Window
System nucleus it it depends on other
Apollo software so it's not a portable
implementation actually I think it was
started before we knew about X which
might explain why it's not portable but
the we've implemented we've we've
modified the Apollo window system so
that it uses the shared nucleus we've
modified the X server so that it uses
the shared nucleus note that then all
we're doing is changing the server
implementation in order to do this this
is a picture of we'd like to see our
changes on some future X release and
this is a picture of how those changes
might come about the we'd propose to
introduce a new directory called wdx for
a window dependent X and and in that
directory there's the WI directory which
is the window independent X which
contains the same old code from the
server now and there's none of the
Apollo directory which contains our
Apollo Pacific version and we would like
to see a more portable shared version
implemented in the future which is what
the question marks are for
okay I'll conclude with two statements
and two questions it appears that old
window systems never die we're trying to
find a place on our screen for one such
system and we're also trying to find
places in our screen for new windows
systems the Window System nucleus is
never done we don't claim that that I
heard that we don't claim that you know
XYZ come what will the Window System
nucleus is solve all the problems but we
we've modified it enough just for X that
we know we'll have to modify it again
but on the other hand it's almost done
first question well users should be able
to handle this complexity with all the
editors and window managers we have
today on one Windows System alone now we
add more windows systems and it can't
help it and increase the complexity we
wonder whether users can make sense of
this and the last question you know what
kind of hybrids will develop if users
start making sense of these multiple
windows systems what sorts of of several
large chunks where each chunk for
example uses a different window system
just because of the natural evolution of
software well that's it
well anyway I think you're supposed to
ask questions now I'm sorry well while
you're asking questions I'll put on my
last slide II know we the attendance
that the the ex-client the all clients
will work as if they've got the whole
street of themselves and the whole
window manager the whole window system
to themselves and then includes the
window managers we intend that WM and
UWM will will work you talked about
layering the Apollo window system on top
of X and that's being sort of
inefficient what about layering X on top
in one Apollo window which is procedure
based it may not be that inefficient
well but you you can't you don't get the
network transparency that way that's the
procedure based system is a local there
no no remote procedure calls or anything
so you're tied to running X on the same
just on the same system as a server in
that case so you'd have to do it the
other way in order to to give something
that was network transparent Thanks
hello yes
say again I'm not gonna dog means the
shared version right not not if it is I
mean the only way that could happen is I
think I understand your question but
possibly not the only way that could
happen is if the Apollo application used
both X and and and the Apollo witness I
mean it'd have to use X in order to do
anything remote so you'd have to modify
the application in order to do anything
remote
okay thanks
[Applause]
I don't have a two
thank you
okay we're back we're gonna be talking
about some the experiences that we had
importing X to a high performance
workstation that included 3d graphics I
will be talking there three of us
talking I'll be talking about some of
the background and the basic
implementation environment in the system
we began this quite a while ago and
actually before x11 began happening we
were looking at what some of the
considerations were for doing 3d
coordinated with bitmap graphics in a
windowing system in April when the x11
design began we were also looking then
very much at the issues involved in
coordinating 3d graphics in X at the
same time we were working on the 3d
graphics interface our initial
definition of that came out at about a
little bit after the end of the public
review on x11 also at about that same
time a figs plus committee started up to
look at adding shading and lighting
curves and surfaces to figs figs is a
ANSI almost standard for 3d graphics and
then a year ago was the first X
conference in performing this work we
were working with pre releases of the
server we had our first functional
server without the 3d extensions running
in December of 86 and we had 3d running
without X on the same device at about
the same time and then it it took us
another few months to get
those coordinated at that time we were
using a bypass mode and we still are for
the 3d where the 3d graphics was
coordinated with X but the actual 3d
requests don't go through an X protocol
then about six months ago we started a
public 3d extension definition which has
been going on since then and that's now
called X 3 deep X there will be a
presentation tomorrow morning which will
go into more detail on pecs there are a
few observations for those lists of
dates one of them was that all of the
components that we were working with
removing targets that included the
hardware all the components of X and the
3d interfaces that we were working with
another aspect of that is that all of
these activities were happening
geographically distributed across the
country so we didn't a lot of times we
couldn't just walk next door to work
issues keeping up and all of these
activities were happening in in parallel
so everyone was made looking at multiple
mailing mailings all the time the
hardware was frozen before any of the
interfaces were really and there were
some things that we could do in
microcode later on in the project and
all of the software that was developed
except for some low-level specific stuff
is source compatible across VMs and
Alteryx ultrix is digital's Berkeley
UNIX product and we wanted to do more
but given the available resources and
that we wanted to have this in a timely
fashion we took some of the some of the
things that we wanted to do and backed
off a little bit from
the environment that we were working
with we standard with we started with
the the standard public releases of the
x11 server re-implemented much of DDX
and used the extension mechanism to add
the additional functions that we wanted
we extended X to support in a highly
interactive 3d graphics interface the 3d
interface is a peer interface with
bitmap graphics and they can be used
simultaneously by clients and we had a
performance emphasis we were we were
trying to to make sure that the window
system did not incur any performance
hits on the overall system the 3d
interface that we implemented has figs
and figs plus like functionality it is
lower level than figs figs is layered on
top of it and it is currently a
structure mode interface originally we
were looking at doing an immediate mode
interface as well we went through the
designs on that and didn't do that again
due to time regular X isn't a an
immediate mode style of interface in
structure mode you create a graphics
data structure in the space of the
server that describes the object that
you want to print or display the
hardware that we were working with had a
lot of support for graphics context it
it could provide asynchronous execution
threads but that was another thing that
we looked at did some initial design and
and didn't complete the implementation
on and you can and there are separate
bitmap graphics and 3d graphics contexts
the hardware also supports when doing
and visuals
window clipping to arbitrary regions
pixel format multiple color maps and
then also a tightly coupled 3d
interaction so that input events can
address can change display directly
without having to loop back this is a
very simple picture of the hardware
model it is a multiprocessor system that
communicates through shared memory the
processors are heterogeneous the server
running in the host processor creates
and modifies data structures in shared
memory the 3d graphics processor in
bitmap graphics processor read the data
asynchronously out of the shared memory
and perform their commands the shared
memory is used for the graphic the 3d
graphics data structures and command
queues for the bitmap graphics this is a
simple diagram of the software model
everything above there is standard X as
its released what was done is that the
d/dx level and below was replaced and
the 3d extension was added the each of
the components the requests coming from
the applications get dispatched to the
appropriate component and then those
create the data structures and shared
memory we also we implemented a bypass
mode that bypasses the protocol and
gives the application library direct
access to the shared memory without
going through a
the transport protocol and we then again
didn't complete the entire 3d protocol
for this ok the next person that will
talk will be Dave Carver
see everybody hear me okay okay
I'm Dave Carver and I'm gonna speak
about the our adaptation of the core X
Server to our favorite piece of hardware
my focus will be primarily on display
management graphics contexts and a
little bit further into the execution
model of X
our hardware provides a as Braco
mentioned provides a multiple window
multiple format environment the frame
buffer can be viewed in many different
ways by the video back-end and in our
implementation we chose to provide one
plane a plane and 24 plane window
capability that comes out in multiple
window depths the visual classes
correspondingly are the pseudo color and
direct color we did have the choice of
doing four and twelve plane windows as
well but we deferred that primarily
because of schedule and resources the
way we chose to present this environment
was to pretend as though our workstation
was a one plane window system or
monochrome system and provide eight and
twenty four planes upon request this
seemed to make sense primarily because
of early on development most
applications and development was was
made on a monochrome system the color
map environment or Hardware does provide
multiple hardware color tables and into
those we can install simultaneously
multiple we installed multiple color
maps one choice we did make was to
reserve one of the hardware color tables
for system use to provide static gray
and true color color maps in our
environment that made sense because the
vast majority of the 24 plane windows
direct color windows are to car windows
needed a particular kind of color map we
chose a gamma corrected color map for
the true color three things that we sort
of found that we needed as we went along
and poly we are still are still needed
our color map conventions and utilities
currently if installation does not
happen properly or has to be D installed
because there are too many column has to
be installed
there aren't the conventions and
utilities provide to the applications to
make that graceful window manager
support would be very very useful and
one other probably more of an it than
anything else we found that given that
we did a default window of one plane and
many of our applications were on top
creating eight and twenty four plane
windows it would be useful to have a
defaulting arrangement for color maps on
a per visual basis
one aspect of our hardware is that it
has very little off-screen memory the
ramifications of this are that well the
memory we do have is organized for
efficient drawing and not for allocation
so the small amount we have is is very
difficult to use for picnics map storage
or font storage or things of that sort
therefore we wind up storing fixed maps
and backing storage in the system memory
our hardware does not support or does
not assist in system memory drawing and
you get as a fall out that you get a
very wide variation performance as you
draw two windows on the screen or pix
maps in system memory the other fallout
is that you wind up with a very high
code complexity trying to cover all the
cases of mixing system memory drawing
with frame buffer drawing and well for
instance copy areas between the two
the hardware supports windowing and
fairly direct fashion provides window
location or translation on the screen as
well as masking and pixel formatting it
also provides bitmap masking above
windows to give a per pixel masking
capability we chose to drive this
capability primarily through the use of
lazy evaluation of the hardware
structures so that if a window
manipulation occurs then we would
generally invalidate the state of the
hardware but we would not reconstruct
the state for the windows until
renditions into that particular window
or a particular window was required the
last note simply depicts that we chose
to do a replacement of the state rather
than sending down editing commands that
was generally because we didn't have
sufficient memory management primitives
in their Hardware the picture depicts
primarily what we do is the ex window
from a next window we construct a
display context as we call it and that
represents a location and clipping
arrangement on the screen from that we
enable that for either bitmap graphics
and as you'll see later on for 3d
graphics as well but the enabling again
is lazily bound it's not doesn't occur
unless either of those kinds of drawing
are actually performed
in in terms of window manipulation to to
the things we wanted to try to do were
to provide overlays and transparencies
the arrangement of our frame buffer
provided for allowing separate areas of
frame buffer being used for let's say
the one plane window then for the 24
plane window in that situation it makes
sense to try to not disturb the drawing
into the 24 plane window by the one
plane window that we these signs of over
look at the sense of the overlay the
transparency again would be to let some
some amount of the one plane window show
above the 24 plane window and we ran
into a number of stumbling blocks and
attempting to do this number one is that
the d/dx interface is a provides
basically two entry points for screen
update there's a copy window function
and a paint window function as a side
note there is no central entry point for
overall update and now there is a
central entry point for database
projection and that procedure is called
the validate tree am i valid a tree the
procedure is an example that that's
provided with the sample server another
thing that's done quite commonly in the
server currently is that a given
windowing manipulation will be composed
of more than one of the more primitive
ones moving might be an unmapped a
reconfiguration of the database and then
a remap d/dx doesn't provide any kind of
a transaction or compositing primitives
so that you can coordinate all that
activity at the device level and those
are all the sort of the things you need
to do in order to provide the
appropriate support for overlays and
transparencies now an argument can be
made that you can sort of get rid of the
the update procedures copy and paint and
really substitute the the validation
procedure with whatever you want to be
done that's possible and and we really
didn't go too far in investigating that
probably required more work than we had
time for next I'll discuss graphics
context management early in the project
our early design considerations and and
this really predates X X version 11 by
at least a few months we started out by
desiring to have extensive drawing state
we anticipated the need for having
multiple threads provided in the
hardware at that time we deemed it would
probably be wise to bind the hardware
state with the thread and another thing
we try to do at that time we're
anticipate we wanted to do is give
direct access to the hardware not only
as prevention for the 3d component but
as also for the bitmap graphic or the
core components as X started to evolve
or x11 started to evolve we had a few
expectations and we tried to program or
design for the flexibility to adapt to
whatever X became we noticed or observe
that x10 was completely state free and
also expected x11 to be much more state
driven and probably quite a bit more
complex we did expect however some
reduce state operators rather than being
fully state driven operators x10 would
become state free operator
you know operator environment I think
that sort of indicates we're looking for
some sort of compromise between x11 the
next 10 at that time also we anticipated
that context editing was a floor was
going to be a frequent operation and
would generally be much cheaper than
doing context switching
well not all of those assumptions and
considerations panned out too well
and basically well one of the areas
where the bite that we we didn't make a
wise choice was to bind together the
state block in the threat of execution
primarily state blocks are switched
frequently and at an application control
and it made sense to not have to switch
threads of execution at the same time
meaning that you'd have to do a full
context switch in execution as well so
we adjusted the microcode to provide
dynamic State block transitions in a
single thread of execution we we backed
off pretty much entirely from direct
access to the hardware for core
operations the reason for that was
because you primarily had to implement
DDX directly by the hardware or
something very akin to that in order to
be able to do that and since our
hardware was a little bit lower level we
didn't have sufficient state to provide
that kind of access we also had the
opportunity to adjust the micro code to
optimize for optimize the drawing state
drop out operators in the state that we
didn't they weren't necessary for X and
we did optimize the context switching
next I'll talk about the execution model
and originally we had high expectations
that we would be able to design a
parallel execution model the goals and
involve that were to try to read reduce
context switching in a throughput for
throughput operations also to provide
priority scheduling and provide well
interactive windows with with a higher
priority and background give background
priority to long term rendering
rendering windows also naturally we
wanted to be able to extend this design
over a multiprocessor environment or a
configuration shortly after we started
that design we ran into a few hitches
and we decided to step back and do a
more thorough investigation of the x11
execution model and a few things came to
light that were quite surprising number
one it was the resource conflicts in the
in the server that determined the amount
of parallelism possible nothing else
really was influencing that the
connection does not influence
parallelism other than operations on a
single connection do have to perform as
though they are serial the atomicity
rule has a fairly important implication
in that you might say well if it's come
if two requests are coming in on
separate connections and they collide on
a resource who cares how badly they they
misbehave the atomicity rule provide
says that you cannot let them collide in
such a way that one look they look like
they collided in parallel one has
happened for the other one question it
came up at the time was that gee
graphics contexts have lots of resources
in them or can reference resources and
that turned out to be a no op in the
sense that those resources can be
considered copy and reference and you
need not factor them into the resource
conflicts when we all summed up what we
you know
what we saw is being required it turned
out that we needed lightweight threads
of execution dynamic state block
allocation and the threads had to be
something that can be created and
destroyed very efficiently
the result of this investigation was
that we backed off to a serial execution
model the the reason we did that is
because the parallel execution model
primarily required resource conflict
management it would impact the D DX and
D is partitioning probably would require
language support and system support in
order to accomplish that the fact that
we backed off to a serial execution
model aggravated the problems we had
with context switching we had no control
over how much how many operations got
executed in particular time in a
particular thread there for applications
that mixed a lot of context switching
perform badly even though we had a lot
of Hardware assist